marriage today cannot be marriage we
have a bunch of leftists ruining the
sanctity of marriage they ruined the
sanctity of marriage when they made gay
marriage legalize again what is marriage
For Better or For Worse or richer for
poor and sickness and in health till
death you do us part it's supposed to be
between a man and a woman that's
marriage we have all of these Modern Day
Men coming in and having open
relationships or modern day women coming
in and basically having open
relationships because they're cheating
on their husband all the time we have
all these men and women that are married
for eight years that's the average
length of marriage how can we say that
we got married when you believe in
getting divorced over chores